as I've been telling you all week
Marjorie Taylor green Republican
congresswoman now wants to be taken
seriously and unfortunately it's looking
increasingly like corporate media is
going to help her there's a really good
article in salon by Amanda Marcotte
which makes a lot of the points that
we've been making on the show this week
about Marjorie Taylor green and Amanda
writes quote Marjorie Taylor green wants
to be a mainstream Republican now sadly
the media will let it happen green is
walking the path laid by the Tea Party
in which today's extremists become
tomorrow's new GOP normal this is a
really good article
um and it points out a few different
things one of them is that there's no
real daylight between the two factions
in in other words the two factions we're
talking about are the pro Kevin McCarthy
pro-trump people and the anti-kevin
McCarthy pro-trump people remember as I
told you yesterday and the day before
you used to have Pro and anti-trump
Republicans
the anti-trump Republicans are still
there but now the pro-trump Republicans
have divided into two the ones that
wanted Kevin McCarthy to be speaker and
the ones that did not Amanda Marcotte
writes in this article that there is a
very good chance that corporate media is
going to allow Marjorie Taylor green to
Rebrand herself in this way that she is
trying to do it's extraordinarily
important that we not be fooled by this
Redemption tour of sorts that Marjorie
Taylor green now is on her perspective
is now that Kevin McCarthy is Speaker I
voted for the speaker Republicans are in
power I can either go the way of being
kind of one of these agitators like
Lauren bobert who she's very much in a
war with at this point in time or I can
be cozy with power
I can get back on committees and that's
very appealing to Marjorie Taylor green
she is clearly desperate for power and
part of this may even be starting to
think about continuing to Lobby to be
Donald Trump's vice presidential running
mate the other thing and this is not
about oh everyone's a fascist that's not
what I'm saying but when we think about
authoritarianism and fascist wannabes
and dictator wannabes fascists will
often do these rewriting of their own
history realignments these sort of
redemption tours if you allow them to do
it they will sort of mention some of my
past views were either mistakes or Jokes
which I regret Marjorie Taylor green did
that on Sunday where she said I got
sucked into some stuff on the internet
like it happens to everybody
and if you allow them they will rewrite
their own history Marjorie Taylor green
is desperate for power she's desperate
for credibility and recognition after
being a joke removed from committees and
essentially a laughing stock for two
years and she's probably angling for
some position of higher power it could
be within Congress it could be as Donald
Trump's running mate she wants to go
from Jewish space lasers to a normal I
fell for some stuff but please forgive
me now I'm really a mainstream
Republican just like Mitt Romney or
something like that corporate media
should not allow her to get away with
that and I have been careful when we
talk about George W bush and I say
listen if you put up a video of George W
bush and you put up a video of trump
obviously George W bush seems normal
compared to Trump but let's not allow
his reputation to be rehabilitated when
he did horrible things as president and
the media corporate media should not
allow Marjorie Taylor green to get away
with what she is very obviously trying
to do like Amanda Marcotte writes I'm
worried they will let her get away with
it but let's hope it doesn't happen
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part go shop plant-based bags to replace
single-use Plastics all over your home
you'll save 20 20 percent when you go to
holdon bags.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below